>>Heath: Hi. My name is Heath. I'm a volunteer
with the Authors@Google team. Thank you for
joining us today. If you'd like to get involved,
or if you have ideas of other authors you'd
like to bring in, please let one of us know.
Today we're here to hear from Wes Moore author
of "The Other Wes Moore: One Name Two Fates",
and by way of introduction I'm just going
to read from the jacket, because I think it
sets it up pretty well.
"Two kids with the same name were born blocks
apart in the same decaying city within a year
of each other. One grew up to be a Rhodes
Scholar, decorated combat veteran, White House
fellow and business leader. The other is serving
a life sentence in prison. Here is the story
of two boys in the journey of a generation."
We're lucky today to have one of those two
men with us today. "Wes Moore is a Rhodes
scholar, a combat veteran of Afghanistan.
As a White House fellow, he worked as special
assistant Secretary Condoleezza Rice at the
State Department. He was a featured speaker
at the 2008 Democratic National Convention
and was dubbed one of the Top Young Business
Leaders in New York by Crain's New York Business.
He currently lives and works in New York City."
And it's a pleasure to have him in Santa Monica.
Wes Moore.
[audience clapping]
>>Wes Moore: Thank you very much. It is an
absolute pleasure to, uh, be here. Um, I am
a huge fan of-of Google for whole collection
of different reasons. First of all, just these
are some of the coolest offices I've ever
been to before, and in particular if you look
at the offices that we work at back in New
York there really is no comparison to a to,
to just how much creativity and openness that
you-that you see here is pretty awesome. Um.
Even though I have to say that last weekend,
when y'all did the whole Pac Man thing that
was the most least productive weekend I've
had in my life.
[audience laughing]
Seriously, I must've spent about eight hours
just tried it figure out trying to get to
the banana level...
[audience laughing]
Moore: ...of Pac Man. But it is really cool
to be here. And actually I have a quick Google
story, which is which is a true story. Um.
Back in the late 1990s, must have been either
'97 or '98. I was at some conference, you
know, how you have these like these young
leaders conferences, whatever. And I was down
at Washington, DC. And I met a guy, ah. And
I met a guy, and he was telling me his name
was name is Larry.
And I was like," Oh, hey Larry. Nice to meet
you." Um, I was like, "What do you do?" and
I-I-I felt real good about myself, because
I was just a new student at Johns Hopkins.
And I was like yeah. I'm on my way and I was
like, "So Larry, what do you do?"
He was like, "Oh, um-I'm um at Stanford. I'm
a graduate student." He was like, "I'm working
on this business. Umm. And it's a, it's a
'search engine.'"
And I was like, "A search engine. Okay, that's
interesting. Cool." And I was like, "What's
the name of it?"
He was like, " It's coming down, but it's
gonna be called Google. You know. It's gonna
be called Google."
I was like, "Yeah, well listen, best of luck
to you with that Google idea."
[audience laughter]
>>Moore: [laughing]
Um. I wish I could go back in time and say,
"I'd love to invest in that idea, actually."
But um- But it is. Seriously, it is very cool
to be here, and I am just very appreciative
of the time, and very appreciative, Ahhh of
our attention. And to all the folks in Googleworld,
it's, ah, great seeing y'all as well.
Ah. I am extraordinarily proud of this book,
and I'm extraordinarily proud of this book
not just because of, you know, the idea of
just getting this but done, uh, but it's the
idea of a conversation this book is starting.
The idea that the book is really creating,
it's really touching a nerve amongst a lot
of people because I think that they are seeing
that this book is about so much more than
just these two boys. That this book is about
so much more than just Baltimore, that this
book is about more than one socio-economic
group. Ah, But this book is really about all
of us. It is about the choices that we make,
the people who we have in our lives who are
helping us make those choices, and also with
the ramifications for those choices..
My-ah-my-my journey really began back in back
in Maryland, and I'm extraordinarily happy
that my two sisters are here in the-in the
audience as well. But our journey really began
in the Maryland. Back in 1982 when I was 3
1/2 years old, our father died in front of
us, and it was something that was so jarring
and so shocking, because here was our-our
mother who at that time was, you know, with
her, you know, with her three children and
her husband, when out of nowhere, instantaneously,
and completely unexpectedly she was on her
own. She was now a widow with these three
children. And she really had a difficult time
dealing with that transition to the point
where a few years after my father passed away,
she moved us up to New York, up to the Bronx.
And, ah, for the Bronx was going through a
very interesting time, because the Bronx during
the mid and late 1980s was going through something
a lot of cities in this country were going
through, and that was the introduction of
little rocks that could be found inside of
little vials that were basically running roughshod
through communities, throughout many communities
in this country. And that was the introduction
of crack cocaine. And you saw what happened
just the internal fabric of entire communities.
My mother, as she grew up in the Bronx, you
know, she always talked about how the Bronx
was a was a place that was a it was a "safe
place" and neighbors they looked out for each
other. And that was one thing that she loved
about the Bronx. She hadn't seen violence
until she actually went down to Washington,
DC to college. But the neighborhood that she
returned back to was a very different neighborhood
than the neighborhood she grew up in. And
I think as the Bronx was going through this
transition, I think all of us were going through
this transition now as well.
Now coming up in this new environment, coming
up in this new community. So as I'm going
in this journey into manhood and trying to
understand what that means at the same time
you're coming from a neighborhood that's going
through its transition, and at the same time,
I'm then really starting to understand what
had happened to us when I was 3 1/2 years
old. Because when you're 3 1/2 years old,
you're enough to know. I was old enough to
know that something happened with my father,
but I wasn't quite old enough though to know
exactly what. And when you're 3 1/2 years
old, you're old enough to know that he'd gone
somewhere, but you're not quite old enough
to understand exactly where. And so as I got
older, and started to internalize it, that
confusion led to anger, that confusion led
to fear, that confusion led to apathy, and
I think it started to manifest itself in a
lot of things I was doing whether it is back
in the classroom or back the neighborhood.
So, by the time I was literally 11 years old,
I was already on academic and disciplinary
probation at my school, and then I was also
now getting in trouble back in the neighborhood.
In fact, there was one time I had a, had a
friend who was also at this time we were both
11, and he was what we called the runner.
Now what of runner is in many communities
that you find these drug enterprises, runners
are generally kids. Who they'll get to move
the packages from one side of town to another
because generally the cops won't check them.
And so the older boys would get the younger
guys they would pay them a little bit of money
so they could move a package, hush, then they
would do it and come back showing that the
package was delivered, and then they would
get their little bit of money or whatever
it was. So I had a friend of mine who was
a runner, and so he just finish work, his
job, and I have just finished playing a game
of basketball, and so he calls-he calls me
out, we start talking. And then he says, "Hey
do you want to tag." And what tagging is,
tagging is essentially just spray painting.
You know, you see walls with spray paint on
it and everyone has their little tags or monikers.
And mine was "Kid Cupid." That was the name
I gave myself. I enjoyed it; I thought I was
"Kid Cupid." And considering my spelling abilities,
I spelled it with a KK instead of KC. And
so he's like, "Do you want to tag?" and I'm
like, "Yeah of course." So we reach inside
his bag and we pull out a can of spray paint.
And I proceeded to do my K and another K put
a circle around it, and that was my little
indelible mark on this Bronx wall. Then out
of nowhere a cop car turns the corner and
you start hearing that "Whoop! Whoop!" You
know, that distinctive police siren, and so
my friend and I looked at each other, and
then we start bolting off in different directions.
He runs in one direction, and I run in the
other direction. I was a really brilliant
one who ran in the direction of the cops.
[audience laughing]
>>Moore: And so literally in, probably about
three or four steps, the cops grabbed me,
put handcuffs on me, and throw me in the back
of the car. My friend, they grab him and throw
him in the back of the car. So at this point,
we're in the back of his car, and I am terrified.
Because I knew, there was only one thing that
could happen next. I was headed off to baby
booking, which is kind of like a juvenile
detention center downtown, and ahhh, then
they'd have to call my mom.
And that was the last thing I wanted was for
them to call my mom, for them to call my mom
and say-- hey you need to come pick up your
son from baby booking. And so I'm sitting
in the back of this car, hands behind my back,
and I am just absolutely freaking out. And
my friend was sitting there with this very
smug and defiant look on his face that quite
honestly just kept bothering me every time
I looked at him.
And so I'm looking at him like, "What are
we supposed to do?" And his answer to me was,
"Just tell them it wasn't you." And I was
a kid I who could make up an excuse for everything,
and even I looked at him and I was like, "That
is the dumbest idea I have ever heard in my
life."
[audience laughing]
>>Moore: And so the cops finally come in,
come into the front seat and look over their
shoulder and asked us, they're like, "So what
are you guys doing?" And then he begins into
his whole "it wasn't me." explanation. I begin
into my whole "I'm so sorry, I'll never do
it again." explanation. And then we're battling
with each other on volume to see who can be
louder in this. And the cops look at us and
they just start giving us a lecture about
what we were doing and how. And then the one
thing he said, he's like, "You know what?
The sad thing is-is we'll probably see you
guys out here doing it again. And then the
cops get out of the car and they let us out
and they take the handcuffs off and they tell
us to get moving. And I realized at that point
after you feel the cuffs off your wrist, what
a break that I got that day. The fact that
they didn't take me down to baby booking,
no one was called, my mother didn't have to
come get me, and I made a vow to myself at
that moment that I would never let that happen
again. Because it was the most vulnerable
feeling that I've ever felt in my life before.
The idea where I knew not only my present
but my future was actually in someone else's
hands.
They controlled me. They controlled my movements.
They controlled my destiny. And I never wanted
to feel that feeling again. And then about
four days later and a couple of blocks later
"kid cupid" was on the loose again. Hanging
out with Shea, putting up marks on these walls.
And so my mother realized at a pretty early
age that something needed to change. And that
this was a direction that I was going in that
she needed to actively get involved to try-to
try-to you know, push me away from.
And so, my mother had been threatening me
with military school since I was about probably
about eight years old. And she'd say listen,
"If you don't get it together, you're going
to military school." And I'd say, "I know
I know. I'm gonna get it together." And then
nine years old came and she said, "You know
I'm serious. If you don't get it together
your go to military school." And I say, "I'm
working on it, really. Just give a little
time. I'm working on it." And then 10 and
11 and then finally 12 years old came and
she said, "You know I'm gonna send you to
military school." And I'd say, "I know. I
know. I know you are. I know. I know." And
she said, "No no, you going next week."
[audience laughing]
>>Moore: And I was like [amusingly] "I'm going
next week," and she's like, "You're going
next week." And at that point, I was then
had to pack up my stuff and start getting
ready to be sent off to this military school.
And so this military school is in a place,
it's a place called Valley Forge Military
Academy. It's in Wayne, Pennsylvania, and
all I'd known up to that point was the city.
I'd known big lights, I'd known big buildings,
I'd known loud noise, I'd known that it's
easier to go to sleep with noise outside then
it is when it is dead silent outside. But
now here I was in this military school in
the middle of Pennsylvania, and I remember
a looking at my mom as she was dropping me
off and thinking to myself I cannot believe
you're sending me off to this place. I cannot
believe that you, you hate me enough that
your gonna send me away. That you don't even
want me in your space anymore. Because I didn't
understand that it was actually the absolute
opposite. That she felt that at that time
what I needed was not necessarily a friend,
but what I needed was a mother.
I needed was someone that was willing to make
a lot of tough decisions in order to help
me get to that point that I needed to be in.
But that first morning at military school
was quite the wake up call. Because that first
morning in military school, we're all sleeping
in our beds, and I'm sleeping on the top bunk,
and my roommate is sleeping on the bottom,
and were both 12 years old. And at 5:30 in
the morning I start hearing Guns and Roses.
And I don't know if y'all remember Guns and
Roses, the-the-the heavy metal group, and
that song "Welcome to the Jungle." And how
it starts: Da-ne-ne-ne-ne-ne-ne-ne, Da na-ne-ne
na-ne-ne-ne, and then it just proceeds to
get louder and louder, and then there are
sirens and Whooooooooo, and all this kind
of stuff.
Then you start, we start, there are lights
then flashing on and off in the hallway. We-
we start hearing the distinctive sound of
trash cans being banged with sticks, and then
people yelling and screaming like they have
absolutely no sense. And you start hearing,
"get up, get up, get out of your racks, please.
Get up, get out here in the hallways." They're
screaming and yelling and cursing, and my
roommate jumps out of bed, and he is and he
is again 12 years old, his legs are like rail
thin. He's a kid from Brooklyn. And he is
looking up in his legs are like shivering,
and he looks up at me and he's like, "Come
on Moore." My last name "Come on Moore. We
got to get up; we got to go in the hallway."
And I look at him and I look at the clock
and the clock says 5:30 in the morning...
[audience scant laughter]
>>Moore: ...and I look back at him. And I
said, "Man, it's 5:30 in the morning." I was
like, "Tell them to get me around eight o'clock.
I should be ready to go about then."
[audience laughing]
>>Moore: And he looks at me, and I don't know
if he, I think he was trying to get in his
mind whether I was just really brave or or-or
just really dumb, but he wasn't gonna stick
around and figure out. So, he runs out in
the hallway. And I roll back over, and I start,
I try to go back to sleep. And I just keep
wondering why they keep making so much noise,
and I wish they would be quiet so I could
go back to sleep.
And they're still yelling outside in the hallway,
then out of nowhere I hear "Why is there only
one person outside of this door!" Then BOOM,
I hear my door fly open, slam the back wall,
chip is like, paint its, paint chips are like
falling off the door. And then my first Sergeant,
who is the 17-18-year-old, comes in and he's
yelling and he's screaming at me and he's
cursing at me and he spitting on the back
of my head and I'm sitting there and laying
in my bed trying to get some sleep.
[audience small laughs]
>>Moore: And so I slowly began to roll over,
and he stops yelling because I think he thinks
this tirade had done the trick and he looks
at me and I look at him and say to him, "Man,
if you don't get out of my room." I'm 12.
He's 18. So, then what he does is he smiles,
and he leaves my room, and so my first thought
is you know this military school thing ain't
bad.
[audience small laughs]
>>Moore: And the next thing I know, probably
about 10 seconds later, BOOM the door opens
slams open again and my entire Chain of Command
walk in the room, and they pick my mattress
up off that top bunk, and then they turned
the mattress over as if I still wasn't on
the mattress, and then I fall five feet to
the ground to this hard floor. And that was
my first morning at military school. And so
needless to say, I didn't like the place too
much. Needless to say that is not my favorite
place in the planet to be at that moment,
and I let them know that, I let my Chain of
Command know that, because in the first four
days I'd already runway four times from the
school. I mean every time they'd turn their
backs, I was running out the gates, because
I kept on trying to find this train station.
Because I knew, there was a train station
somewhere in Wayne, Pennsylvania. I had heard
this. And I knew the train station in Wayne
and I could take that to the 30th street,
and take 30th street to Penn Station. Penn
Station I could hop on the 2 train take that
one up to the Bronx. Walk from the Dunhill
Road stop in the Bronx, and walk back home.
I had the whole thing mapped out, as to how
this
whole thing would go down, as long as I could
just find this train station.
So, my squad leader comes in my room after
the fourth day, and my roommate and I are
sitting in-in our-in our respective chairs.
And my squad leader walks in, my roommate
calls room to attention, and we both get to
attention. And he tells my roommate to get
out, and so now I'm scared, because I'm like,
something is about to go down and he doesn't
want any witnesses.
[audience faint laughter]
>>Moore: So, my roommate scurries out of the
room and goes and whatever. And my squad leader
tells me to take a seat, and I take a seat
he grabs a chair turns a backwards like we're
old buddies having a chat, and he's like,
"listen you don't want to be here, and quite
honestly we don't want you here. So, I've
drawn you a map on how to get to this train
station." Because he was basically saying
how pathetic my attempts to find this train
station were. And so I'm looking at this map
like he just handed me a piece of gold. I
mean I'm like I'm getting like tears welled
up in my eyes. I'm like, "listen, I'll never
forget you, man. When you get to the outside
let me know." And he just looks at me and
he's just like just get out of here, just
go.
So, I have my- I plan out my whole great escape.
The whole great escape so figured like taps,
taps in the military, taps is lights out.
When they play the bugle, the dun-dun-dun-dun,
dun-dun-dun. Taps 10 o'clock lights go out.
I figured, you know what, I can set my alarm
for 11:30 because everyone should be asleep
by then, but that'll still give me a good
head start before 5:30 in the morning wake-up
call. So by the time they figure out that
I'm gone I could already be long gone. So
this is, kind of like, like you know like
in Shawshank redemption. I had the whole thing
planned out and so my alarm goes off, I put
it under my bed, I quickly shut off the alarm,
jump out of bed, and I grab my little bag,
my little map, my little flashlight. I say
peace to my roommate and I'm gone. I run out
the doors. And I go through the gates, and
I'm going into the woods, where I'm following
this map. And so the map is telling me take
10 paces this way, and make a left at a big
rock, and then take 20 paces this way, and
make a right at a big tree. I'm thinking to
myself there is nothing in the rocks and trees
I hear man. What rocks and trees do you talk
about? But I keep on trying to follow this
map, and I go out and it is just taking me
deeper and deeper and deeper into the woods.
And at this point remember, I'm from the city
and so I don't know anything about these woods.
And so my imagination at this point at 12
years old is just running wild. I am hearing
snakes and bears and tigers and elephants
and all things that weren't there, but that's
just my imagination at that point. So I sit
down and I just start crying because there's
that I wanted to do more at that point than
just to go home. There's nothing more I wanted
more at that point then for people to just
leave me alone, and let me be and so I sit
down and just start crying. And then I start
hearing more leaves rustling, and I figured
it was just more bears and more elephants
and then I started hearing laughter.
The laughter was my Chain of Command that
followed me out to that day the map was fake.
The map took you to the middle of the woods.
They just wanted to see how bad I wanted to
go home. And at night they got their answer.
I wanted to go home pretty bad.
So they took me back to campus and we were
in the middle of something called plebe system.
And what plebe system is the first six weeks
you in military school where you have zero
communication with the outside world, and
no phone calls, no television, no e-mails,
no Google, no anything. All of it's cut off.
And the whole point is that they want a break
you down as individuals, and-and then build
you up back as a team for six weeks. And so
out of no where, they say to me they're like,
"If we don't make some break in the rules
we're going to lose him. So, Moore you've
got five minutes to make a phone call. We
don't care who you call, but you've got five
minutes to make that phone call." And I call
the only number that I knew, which is my mom.
So, I dial her number, and I'm on the phone,
and so my mother at this point she wasn't
expecting to hear from me for six weeks because
we are in the middle of plebe system. And
now in the first four days, at one o'clock
in the morning she gets a call from me. So
she has no idea
what's going on; so she's like, "Are you okay?"
"Huh, yeah I'm fine, but you know, it's really
bad here. They treat you terribly, the food
is horrible, they wake you up early in the
morning." and I'm like, "If you just let me
come home, I'll do what it takes to do better,
I'll clean my room, I'll clean your room,
I'll do what ever you want me to do, just
let me back home."
And then she stopped me and she said, "Too
many people have sacrificed in order for you
to be there." she said, "Too many people are
working too hard and too many people are rooting
for you, and they just want you to give it
a shot." And she said, "Your father's looking
down on you, and he's proud of you, and he
just wants you to try."
The sacrifices she's talking about, I didn't
realize it at that point, I didn't appreciate
it at that point, but what she was talking
about were things like, not only the emotional
sacrifices she was making for this, but that
military school wasn't free and it wasn't
cheap. So, my mother ended up actually asking
friends and family and coworkers to give what
they could in order for her to do it. And
eventually when she realized she was still
thousands of dollars short, my grandparents,
who we actually moved up with to live in the
Bronx, then actually took the money out of
their home and gave it to my mother.
My grandparents immigrated to this country
just a few little over two decades earlier,
because my grandfather want-my grandfather
was following his dream in becoming a minister.
And he became the first black minister in
the history of the Dutch Reform Church. And
they bought a small home up in the Bronx,
when they first moved to this country. My
grandfather was a minister and my grandmother
was a public school teacher. And they bought
this home not just they were looking for shelter,
but because they wanted to own a piece of
this country that took them in. And when they
realized my mother was going to be short,
and they realized I was at a crucial point
in my life. At a point that comes for so many
kids in particularly for young buys. Where
that split can happen so quickly, and those
decisions can become so jarring that they
knew they had to do something. So they ended
up taking all the retirement money out of
that home and giving it to my mother, so she
could afford this school. And so I'd be lying
to say if at that moment, I fully made any
type of turn. It took a while, but later on,
as I was there a little longer I began to
understand what my mother was talking about.
Later on as I got older and I was there a
little longer, I began to understand what
sacrifices she was talking about, and I began
to understand concepts like accountability
and responsibility and leadership. And why
those became so important in terms of larger
development.
And if you fast-forward later on, I actually
join the military to become an Army officer
and going on to Johns Hopkins University.
And that's where the origins of this book
began. Because one day, I received-I had just
received the Rhodes scholarship. And the day
after I received the Rhodes scholarship the
Baltimore Sun, which is my hometown paper,
ended up doing a piece on my childhood and
life and how I had some issues coming up,
but through a lot of help and support and
intervention that I receive this award.
Around the same time, they were running a
whole series on four guys who robbed a jewelry
store. Two guys walked into a jewelry store
with guns; two guys walk into a jewelry store
with mallets. The two guys with guns went
in first, and they got everybody on the ground,
and everybody that was inside the store got
on the ground and kept their heads down. And
the two guys with mallet then followed them
in.
One guy with a gun and one guy with a mallet
went to the right. One guy with a gun in one
guy with mallet went to the left. And then
proceeded to walk around the jewelry store
smashing the cases taking out rings and watches
and necklaces. And they got away with about
a little over $400,000 worth of jewelry that
day. And then one of them yelled let's go,
and then all four ran out of the store.
One of the people who were on the ground,
was an off-duty police officer who is moonlighting
as a security guard. That police Sergeant
was a thirteen year veteran of the police
force. He was a three-time recipient of Officer
of the Year Award, he was a father of five,
he had triplets and the reason he was working
that day because he was trying to make extra
money for his family.
As the four guys ran out of the store and
ran into the parking lot. He then got up and
ran after them, trying to stop them from getting
away and he went to the parking lot and he
was hiding next vehicles to try to see if
he could find out where they were and to see
if he can keep them from getting away. And
he didn't realize that one of the vehicles
that was kneeling next to was one of vehicles
that they were in, and then a window rolled
down and three shots were taken at point-blank
range and he was killed instantly. And the
two cars sped away.
Sergeant Prothero, the person that was killed
that day, was a hero. He was a person of honor
and integrity and character and every shred
evidence that you can find about him says
exactly that. And then three shots at .point-blank
range ended his life. And there was a 12-day
national manhunt for these four guys and finally
all four were caught. The last two were caught
in Philadelphia, and as I discovered, both
by wanted posters that were inside the neighborhood,
and also by the series of articles in the
Sun and all the other papers inside of the
area, because this crime was a big deal.
I discovered that one of the guys that was
caught was living in the same area that I
was living in, was around the same age that
I was, and his name was also Wes Moore.
See here you have stories, articles about
these two kids around the same age living
in Baltimore. One ends up getting this scholarship
to go on to England, and the other ends up
serving life in prison without the possibility
of parole.
Him, his older brother, and two other guys
who were there that day. And the story haunted
me, because I began asking myself, how does
that even happen? How does it happen that
you have two kids who have similar backgrounds
who end up in two completely different places?
What were those factors inside of their lives
that ended up causing such a significant split?
And so few years after I first learned about
the other Wes Moore, I couldn't escape it,
and I couldn't shake it. So, I ended up writing
the note in prison, I ended up writing him
a note a not sure I'd ever hear back from
him and in many ways it didn't even matter.
But I knew these were questions I wanted to
ask, and I knew he was the only one I could
actually get answers from. And then a month
later I get an envelope back from Jessup Correctional
Institution from Wes Moore.
And in the letter the first thing that he
writes is he first thanks me for writing him,
because he says, "When you're in prison you
believe the world doesn't think you exist
anymore." And then he proceeds to answer off
answers to all the questions that I asked
him. And the answers intrigued me. The answers
intrigued me on a whole collection of different
levels. To the point that eventually I decided
to write him again, and that one letter turned
into dozens of letters, and those dozens of
letters have now turned into numerous visits,
and I've now known him around five years.
And a few years ago a friend of mine, who
is an author, actually knew that I had reached
out to Wes and knew that I had gotten to know
him. And said, "I think there's something
larger here, I think there's a bigger truth
that needs to be explored here, I think is
a book project here."
And at first, I was actually very reluctant
to do so. I felt like I didn't have time.
I felt like I didn't want to explore his life
that deeply and quite honestly I didn't want
to explore my own life that deeply. And there
are a couple things that really pushed me
to do it.
The first thing I thought about was the tragic
death of that police Sergeant. And if this
is something that can be helpful and help
these tragedies from happening again, than
I thought it was important to do, because
as Edmund Burke said, "All it takes for evil
to triumph is for good people to do nothing."
And then I thought about something that Wes
had told me. Because when I talk to Wes about
it he said, "You know I've wasted every opportunity
I've ever had in life, and I'm going to die
in here. So if you can do something that can
help people understand the ramifications for
their decisions, and also help people understand
the neighborhood these decisions are being
made in then I think you should do it."
And that became the baseline that became the
foundation for this entire story. And the
baseline and foundation for this entire journey.
And there's a lot of things I wanted to explore
with this story, and a lot of things are wanted
to explore what this book. As I went through
the process of putting this whole thing together,
it took over 200 hours of interviews with
Wes, his friends, and family and my friends,
and family. Just to make sure that you're
really getting the facts and the feel of the
story right. To interview Wes when you walk
into a maximum-security facility is the kind
of place that no matter how many times you
go that feeling will never escape you. The
sounds of bars closing behind you, the sounds
of police officer's the rubber soles squeaking
on the ground, the sites of prisoners being
marched in-in their uniforms, the smells.
These are things that will never escape you
when you walk into a maximum security facility.
But every time I went to see Wes and actually
do these interviews, I was never allowed bring
any type of pens, any paper, any tape recorders,
and any chewing gum, nothing. When you go
see him you're searched twice every time you
go in. He's searched every time he got visitors
area and you just sit together in the visitors
area for an hour before a guard comes taps
you on the shoulder, or taps him on the shoulder,
and says times up, and then escorts him back
through the gates, and then the visitors go
back where they came from.
And so as I was doing these interviews with
Wes, I would sit for the hour and talk with
him, and thenonce the guard said it was time
I would then have to go back to the car, run
back to the car, and I would go back to the
car where I had a tape recorder waiting on
the seat of my car. And then I would sit there
and regurgitate for the next 20 minutes everything
he said, so I'd have it all down. And then
I'd go back and later and transcribe it. And
some of the things that we talked about, some
of the issues that we talked about and some
of the dynamics we talked about were so amazingly
stirring and so amazingly jarring. Some of
the things we talked about and some of the
challenges and wasted opportunities and the
things that I've learned about Wes for example:
Wes is not a dumb guy by any stretch of the
imagination. He's made unforgiving decisions
with completely irreversible results, but
he's not a dumb guy.
And you think about the shame that it is,
and obviously not just the obvious tragic
loss of the police Sergeant. But the shame
that this is a person that could be doing
something else, but will never have that opportunity
again. And the thing that I realized throughout
this entire process was it helped me to understand
and to recognize our potency as a society,
because fundamentally what you had were two
kids who at similar times in our lives were
searching for more. Two kids at similar times
in our lives were searching for help, and
one kid got it, and the other kid didn't,
and now the world bears witness to the final
results of either our attention or our apathy,
our focus or our indifference. What we fundamentally
had is a situation, where you had two kids
who could have been moved in either direction
to the point that I felt it was even on the
cover of the book where I say, "The chilling
truth is that this story could've been mine
and the tragedy is that my story could've
been his." But the decisions and the people
we have in our lives to help us make this
as you are helping us to make those decisions
help lead to final fates.
I'm a firm believer throughout this entire
process that this concept of fate for me has
completely been turned on its head, because
I don't believe in this idea of predestined
fate I don't believe in the idea that people
are born to be X or people are born to be
Y. I believe that potential in this country
is universal but opportunity is not. And that
space that difference between potential and
results is where we all come in. That space
and that difference between what we could
be and what we actually are is where parents
and teachers and role models and mentors and
supporters come in, because I want people
understand our potency.
The entire point of this book was not to create
something people can pick up and look at and
say wow that's great story and kind of throw
it off to the side. The point of this book
is that it's a call to action. The point of
this book is that people can pick up this
book and see that this book is about so much
more than just two kids. But it's about all
of us. It's about the society we live in and
the society that we hope to live in.
One of the things that I'm most proud of in
this book is actually in the back of the book
where there is a resource guide. Where I lay
out over 200 organizations around the country
who are on the ground doing the work. It's
a place to go to help, and it is a place to
go for help. And I've been so inspired by
not just a reaction to the book, and not just
the reaction to the stories, but that the
fact that people are using this as an opportunity
to get involved.
I had a mother and a son over in Gaithersburg
at a book festival in Maryland, who came up
to me and said they were reading the book
together. And they said that the thing that
they're going to do is when they're done reading
the book they're going to decide which one
of these organizations they are going to support
and go volunteer together.
I had a woman down in Atlanta who took the
bus, took the Greyhound bus from South Carolina
all the way down to Atlanta to go to the Jimmy
Carter Library where I was talking or I was
speaking a few days back just so she could
tell me about me the organization that she
works with and why they are doing such good
work and why I need to include them in the
next edition of the book.
We can make a huge difference. There is a,
we have a Facebook page for the book, and
there is a, there was a woman, there was a
teacher at an alternative school in Baltimore
who posted on the wall, that she wanted, that
she needed books for some of her students
that she works with because she thinks that
they can really gain from these stories and
get a better understanding about their life.
And then
someone contacted her and shipped her six
copies of the book so she could give to her
students.
There was a 14-year-old man in Baltimore,
who wrote me a few weeks back, who's been
in and out of the juvenile justice system
inside of Baltimore growing up. And one of
his older friends told him to read the book,
and he said he begrudgingly did. And he said
it was the first book he's ever read cover
to cover, but he said the book and he said
he felt inclined to write me, because he said
this book made me think more about the type
of man I want to become, and the role that
I have inside of my family.
I want people to understand our potency. I
want people to understand our roles. And the
fact that if we had the time and the inclination
we can genuinely change lives as long as were
willing to do it. My mother says it all the
time and I think she is absolutely right.
She says," Kids need to think that you care,
before they care what you think." And as long
as were willing to show young people that
we care; it's amazing the type of results
they will be willing to show us.
So thank you all for your time, and thank
y'all for your continued service. It's greatly
appreciated. Thank you so much.
[audience applause]
>>Moore: What I would what I would love to
do, ahhh either from folks in the room or
folks in Googleland, is take any questions
that uh, that people might have about the
process or whatever, anything. Yes sir.
>>male #1: Did the other Wes Moore have a
chance to read the book?
>>Moore: Thank you. Yes. The question was
has the other Wes Moore had a chance to read
the book. Uh, he had. Matter of fact actually
I send them a copy of the book even before
was released. He really had two main thought
the first thought he was just amazed at how
much research went in to it, and it was amazing
that I got all the facts right, because this
was really a long process. Because everything
that you got, not only from his site that
from my side, had to be not only checked and
corroborated and double checked so just to
make sure that everything that you include
inside there is actually accurate and it holds
up to that standard. Umm, and so he was just
amazed at how much research went into it.
And the other thing that he said was as we
were getting a chance to read his life in
a book like that. He
said it amazed him at how little he's done
with his life. And that was his reaction,
so.
An-But it's interesting because when I first
decided to actually turn this into this, and
as I said you know, Wes really one of the,
you know, one of the one of the main reasons
in what he said to me. Ah. His friends and
family weren't as open to it, but I knew only
way I can get the proper stories out was if
they were open and they cooperate.
I remember I went to talk, there's one character
in the book, uh, one of Wes's good friends
Woody, and I remember when I first got a chance
to meet Woody. And I'd say to Woody, "Woody,
here's something I'm working on. So Woody,
how was school for you growing up?" He's like,
"It was cool." Thanks Woody. "So how was ah
you know, so what was school like?" "It was
fine." And that's I mean I was not getting
anything from Woody and then one day, I think
it was like a Thursday, I got a call from
Woody. And what he's like, "Hey Wes, so, what
are you doing on Saturday?" I'm like, "Nothing.
Why?" And he's like, "I talked to Wes, and
he says you're a good dude, and he says you're
just trying to help some kids."
So he's like, "I'm going to show you some
things." And so then we spent all day Saturday
going by old spots, old neighborhoods, where
he just downloaded, I mean downloaded to the
point, I was like alright Woody. I've seen
enough I don't need to see anymore. I got
it thanks."
But I mean, but and he-he, and this is just
one example who became extraordinarily helpful
in making sure you're really getting the story
correct. Umm, and but had it not been for
Wes pushing his people to do that, and then
also my pushing my family to do that because
there's certain things in the story, which
were difficult to learn about. There are certain
anecdotes, which I had no idea about. But
it was really you telling people that you
really needed the story and you needed the
story correct because that was the only way
I knew it can make a difference was how we
were able to get the story done but those
are really Wes is main reactions.
He said it was it was it was in some ways
tough for him to read it, because he realized
how little he's done with his life. Yes ma'am.
>>female #1: [inaudible]
>>Moore: Yeah. Riverdale. Well, actually,
I did not and I'll tell you about Riverdale.
I'm sorry, Yeah.
>>female #1: Well, I was wondering what your
views...[inaudible]
>>Moore: Thank you very much. The question
was about if I had gone to public schools
or what my view is on educational reform.
How much time do we have because I've got
a lot of views on education in this country?
A lot of views.
First, on I think in many ways going to Riverdale
for me, for those who don't know Riverdale
is almost it's a private school out side the
Bronx. And my mother at that time was working
three different jobs in order to send us away
because she was very uncomfortable with the
schools inside the neighborhood, particularly
as she saw how the neighborhood was changing.
Umm, where I went to school, wher-wher-where
we lived there is a school right up the street
called Evander, which was kind of our neighborhood
public school. Evander actually made national
news, and can't remember what year was in
the early '90s but that was when a young girl
was actually shot in the face at Evander high
school. This is a test, so my mother made
a decision very early this is just thought
this is not going to be where I send my children.
So she worked these multiple jobs in order
to send us to this school, um, which was interesting
to me because it's an extraordinary place
and-and-and it's my problem was in many ways
was I was not ready for it. And my problem
was that I felt myself very much on an island
at the school, because coming from the neighborhood
and going across town to the school you increasingly
find yourself alone no matter where you went,
because you went to you very quickly became
too rich for the kids in the neighborhood
who didn't understand why he had to go all
the way across town to go to school. And then
you became too poor for the kids in school
who didn't understand why you live all the
way on the other side of the Bronx.
And so you found, and so I found myself not
being comfortable anywhere, and I think that
really
manifested itself in a lot of acting out and
trying to gain acceptance wherever I could
find it from your friends. And one thing you
realize about friends is when they tell you
to do X, Y, and Z and you could do it and
you get in trouble and you look around for
your friends and they're nowhere to be found
that's just about, as much as that friendship
is worth. Um. And so I think in many ways
that even though my mother obviously had the
best intentions, it was really the place I
got most got lost.
Ah. How I feel about larger educational reform
are a couple of different things. One of the
things that I think military school was useful
for me; not so much because I waspicked up
from one environment and put into another
enviroment but because actually I think it's
almost the wrong answer for most kids.
Where it's just you know it's just take a
handful from here put them somewhere else
and we think we've solved education in this
country. It's backwards and this is not true.
Um.
But one thing I do believe was the transition
that happened to me with the psychological
transition, ah, at that point was I went to
an environment where our motto was "No excuses
No exceptions." I went to an environment where
the expectations of what is going to do was
raised significantly. There's actually a scene
in the book when Wes and I are talking about
our environments and how he grew up in
the neighborhoods and grew up in and then
I say to him do you think that we're products
of our environments? And he looks at me and
he says I think we'll actually were products
of our expectations. Which I thought was a
really important distinction, because he said
the expectation of you or the neighborhood
you are living in is that you'll finish school,
was that you will go on to college, you will
go on and get a job in common you will be
a productive husband and father or mother
and wife. Then that's generally what you'll
do.
But if the expectation of you and the community
that you live in is that he probably won't
finish school, you'll probably end up in the
juvenile justice system, you'll probably end
up in and out of facilities for the rest of
your life. Then kids have a funny way of proving
you right on that angle as well. And so that's
why I think this whole concept of raising
expectations and being able to look at the
larger school reform platform becomes incredibly
important not just for individual communities
but for our nation as a whole.
Because the challenge that we have you have
if you have communities in our society where
you have 50 and 60% dropout rates for kids
who enter. If you have communities and societies
in our country where you have 17% kids of
color who are reading it grade level by third
grade, we've got a real problem, because we
got a significant amount of underutilized
assets within our country and there's no way
that you can continue to compete nationally
as long as you have so many underutilized
assets. So, I have a whole to say about of
school reform in this country. The beautiful
thing is though and even some of the organizations
we include inside the book they are people
who are doing it right. It's not like this
is a complete broken we don't know what to
do. We know what to do because people are
doing it.
The question is how are we identifying them,
how are we scaling them, how are we supporting
them, and how are we making those types of
opportunities open and accessible to everybody?
Because we can't have so many of "the others"
in our society, because it's going to be"the
others" that is really going to make the difference
between who we want to be and who we are.
I'm sorry ye- do you want to follow up?
>>female in audience: [inaudible]
>>Moore: ...can't make them drink...yeah.
>>female: And I was wondering, what is the
water? [inaudible]
>>Moore: It's a great point. Thank you. It's
obvious you've read the book. And it's a great
point because there is a point where Wes and
Tony are talking. Tony is Wes's older brother
and Tony, heh, Tony, Tony is a, ah fascinating
character. Tony had left school by the time
he was in eighth grade. Tony had been involved
in drugs in Baltimore before his aides had
even hit double digits. But Tony made it a
point from a very early age to try to keep
Wes out.
He specifically would tell Wes continually
listen you're not built for this, and you're
not built for this game. And you're too smart,
you need to go to school, you need to finish
up. Tony kept trying to drive us away from
the life of Tony had come to know. Is actually
an interesting dynamic. Because that actually
happens a lot in many communities where you
find older brothers who are trying to look
out for the little brothers trying to basically
say do as I say not as I do. And the scene
where it's you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make him drink. Was Tony went to
Wes's house and saw a whole tower high, you
know, row of sneakers lined up in Wes's room,
and Tony pulled Wes outside and said, "Where'd
you get this money from? And Wes said, ""Oh,
I'm making the money DJing." And Tony was
too smart for that, and this was when Wes
was 12-13 years old. And Tony looked at him
and said, "I know you didn't make this money
DJing, not at 12 years old. I' gonna ask you
again. Where did you make this money from?"
And then Wes began to say, oh, I made this
money DJing,. Before he could even get it
out Tony punched him in the face and started
beating him up in the front lawn. And his
mother came outside and started to break them
up and pulled them off to the side she said,
"What's going on here?" And Tony was like,
"Wes is out here hustling." And in his mothers
like, "No he's not, he's make the money DJing,.
That's what he told me." And Tony kind of
pulls off to the side. And he's like, "Do
you really believe that?" And he put his hat
back on and he said, "You know what? I'm done.
I'm done talking about it." And then he said,
"'You can lead a horse to water but you can't
make him drink.'" And he said, "If you need
to learn these lessons the hard way you'll
learn these lessons the hard way."
But it was interesting that scene later on
with the job corp. Wes had a chance to go
to Job Corp because he'd been involved in
drugs for a while. But he went to Job Corp
and Job Corp was a program was started under
Lyndon Johnson, as almost really a second
chance.
So, Wes got a chance to get his GED in the
Job Corp, he found out he was reading at a
sophomore in college reading level through
the Job Corp, he started learning carpentry
skills, he built a beautiful house for his
daughter through the job corp. And he left
Job Corp, he left Job Corp and I remember
him telling me, he said, " That was...," he
said, " That was the best experience of my
life going to job corp."
Because he said," I came out so involved and
so empowered. And I knew I wanted to do right."
But then as he returned back to the streets
of Baltimore, so many of the problems he had
thought he left behind. He realized they were
just there waiting for him and they were just
compounded at that point because now Wes had
four children. Now Wes had two mothers' of
his children who both needed money; his mother
needed help. And Wes was making $6.50-7.00
and hour doing odd jobs because, you know,
as a felon your not going to, there's a whole
lot of jobs you're not even eligible for.
And so I say that and share that not necessarily
to make people sympathize with Wes. I say
that not to have any revisionist history about
what happen, because Wes made the decision
to go back to the streets.
Because he said he couldn't wait; he needed
the money. But I say that because we have
to understand the dynamics of what challenges
are actually going on. And understanding why
we have 70% recidivism rates in this country.
It is important that we understand the dynamics
of what are taking place, and not just what
is this society that people are coming back
into, but wha-how are we preparing people
to come back into society? Because the fact
is, 95% of the people in prison are coming
out. Only 5% are like Wes, who are in there
for life without parole. 95 are coming out
so how are we preparing not only society,
but them for that type of re-entry?
[whispering] What was that? okay.
>>female: If anybody wants their book signed...
>>Moore: Okay, sorry.
>>female: It's just that we have to go...
>>Moore: Sorry. Again I want to thank everybody
for your time an-and just for the curiosity
and for all of your hard work. Its just greatly
appreciated and your support is greatly appreciated.
And we are genuinely making a difference as
long as we continue pushing. Thank y'all so
much. Thank you.
[audience applause]